it's time now for CBS deals and this
morning the warm weather is finally upon
us for some that means picnics and
spending time at the beach and with that
in mind we have a few items that might
make your day a bit brighter and more
fun in all exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan that QR code on your
screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Ashley Bellman joins us
now with more good morning good morning
I think somebody's ready for summer we
are ready for summer go to cbsdeals.com
this is just the start of a plethora of
so many great items and the deals are
incredible do explain okay starting with
Mission so they have this cooling fan
here turn it on there it is this is
going to make you feel 55 degrees
there's an ice pack in here so even on
the hottest days it could be 95 degrees
out hot humid you're on the golf cart
you are sitting in the arena at the
concert I'm walking to the the
playground with my son and my dog just
flashing and it is hot but that is this
is no ordinary fan for 27.50 you could
get the air around you to 55 degrees so
it's like portable air conditioning can
you drink in it no this is not a water
bottle this is just to cool you down 27
50 50 off you're getting the fan that's
going to cool you down and the towel
this you wet it you wring it out you put
it on you and for two hours you're gonna
stay cool nice so think of what you're
doing this summer think of the Heat and
then think of being cool and comfortable
all summer long so for those of us our
bread always spoils you got something no
this is the Tupperware bread saver not
only does it make your pantry organized
it makes it look fabulous I just
reorganized everything I love this you
could put your bread in here the
ventilation on the top here is going to
make sure it's not going to get moldy
the grooves on the bottom here are going
to make sure that the bread does not get
stale for 20.99 you can put two
different types of bread in here I like
whole wheat my husband likes Rye so one
Bread Box and then I'll love too for my
pastries when I go to get to the bakery
where do I put it when I get home throw
it in the Tupperware bread saver box 30
off today savings are incredible you're
going to use this all the time I'm
telling you this is really and it saves
you money because yeah going back to the
store okay all right every kid's dream
every and every adult stream wow Sports
makes the best products cvsdeals.com I'm
telling you the deals start at they go
up to 31 off 79.99 to make your backyard
the place to be this summer if you have
the pool great we have this amazing
float my grandma's house I always think
back to the sprinkler and running
through that when I was little in the
Nostalgia that happened imagine having
the sumo wrestler Splash Pad imagine
having the rainbow sprinkler the Hoops
or all three of these things I see you
eyeing up that side
she took her shoes off
if you're if you're gonna get in then I
I'm gonna have to as well but just but
picture being the place to be this is
kind of nerve-wracking All Summer Long
think of them people spend so much money
on the moon bounces on all those things
yeah every time every time
but I mean kids and adults alike
all summer long
oh I'm supposed to tease something over
there thank you so much
all of these companies get it to get
these deals so to buy anything you saw
today especially the sumo just scan that
QR code on your screen or head on over
to cbsdeals.com